so if i said to you do you care about
your privacy as a user they would say of
course I do but if I then said to you do
you care that is if you go to a website
that they may actually be able to know
that you clicked on an ad and that that
might actually get you some better
content on that web site they might say
no I thought it's going to help me
how much is your online privacy worth to
you a right once regarded as sacrosanct
in the analog days of yesteryear today
it feels as if our entire lives have
been out sourced recent TV went to south
by southwest in austin texas and caught
up with danelle dixon ther Mozilla's
chief legal strategists to find out what
we should do with all that data with
over a hundred and fifty thousand
participants crowding every hotel and
conference room our cameras caught up
with her on the sidewalk about the only
free space left in the entire city I'm
Paul Dietrich with recent TV and today
we're talking with danelle dixon ther of
mozilla she's the vp of business and
legal affairs at mozilla thank you for
joining us today thank you for having me
well let's just talk generally about the
future of online business you say that
the like data companies should be on the
offense not on the defense when it comes
to users privacy users data like you
just talk about that for us yeah so from
from our perspective and certainly from
my personal perspective I think that
it's so important for companies as
they're starting up and particularly for
developers to think about data and data
hygiene and how they're actually going
to take data and in use that data
internally when they're going to start
overriding that data and how they're
going to be so transparent with their
users about it because one of the things
that I think in the technology space
it's so important it's trust is our
currency and if we actually don't have
the trust of our users we actually
aren't going to be successful as a
company so starting that trust out from
day one is really really important you
say that it may be good business sense
to be up front like be up front in the
first place with with user data yeah I
think it's the most important thing to
do I think so much of what happens on
the internet today is that users don't
understand that value exchange about
what they're getting in return for the
data that they're giving to these
companies I see this so much in the
advertising space that you just don't
understand it I think if they did they
would be much more open to that exchange
of information and so I think that if
you start a company and this is one of
the things you're thinking about right
outside the box then you're actually
sure you're creating that trust and you
are going on the offensive because
you're saying we care enough about you
to be able to describe for you what
we're doing let's talk about politicians
how much do politicians know about data
usage privacy how much do they know
about these these
these particular tech issues so i think
that politicians themselves they have
such a gamut of issues they have to
cover so they themselves don't actually
probably understand all of those issues
the good news is we have really smart
staffers that work with them and those
staffers are the ones that actually
track those issues I think that let's
just be honest I think that the average
user out there it doesn't understand
anything about it and then most of these
politicians aren't even and on par with
the average user because they have so
much they're doing in their daily lives
let's talk about Mozilla Mozilla has
been on sort of the forefront of
standing up for individual rights on the
Internet what is Mozilla done with the
Freedom Act so what we did in the
Freedom Act which is something that we
normally don't do is actually support
legislation and it was a little bit of a
strange thing because we're supporting
legislation that's amending the Patriot
Act which isn't something that we would
have stood behind right the Patriot Act
but the reason why we supported the
Freedom Act is because so much of what
happened within which Snowden with what
the Snowden revelations remember us is
that the the the day the bolt collection
of data and the fact that the tech
companies can't be transparent about
what requests they're getting those were
two pieces of this the Freedom Act that
we thought were really important to
support and so we did that so not only
do we need to be transparent with our
users about how we're collecting data we
need to educate ourselves in that text
base about the importance of what what
can happen with governments not only our
government but other governments so I
think that that's a really important
thing that people who are starting these
businesses need to think about and also
those of us who are in the business need
to continue to think about you said the
privacy doesn't mean anything to
developers like the term it's such a
it's such a I don't know it's such a
term that's like turns people off it
doesn't get people it doesn't speak to
developers why is that so I don't only
think it doesn't speak to developers I
think that if i said to you do you care
about your privacy you would of course
have to say of course I do but what does
that mean to you what is your privacy
mean to you and that's one of the things
that's not just developers it's the
average user people don't understand
like other than just saying privacy yeah
I care about keeping some stuff private
they don't understand what privacy by
design might meet must might mean and I
think so much of it is about data and if
we can just talk in terms of data
because that's what so much of it is
used online then I think that everybody
can get a clearer picture about what
we're doing I want to talk about the
measures that we're putting in place to
protect your data which will help to
protect your privacy but like just
saying privacy in and of itself doesn't
I don't think
to the whole picture but even
individuals users themselves don't care
about these issues as much as they might
should well I think that users might
again if it's phrased in so if i said to
you do you care about your privacy as a
user they would say of course I do but
if I then said to you do you care that
is if you go to a website that they may
actually be able to know that you
clicked on an ad and that that might
actually get you some better content on
that web site they might say no I
thought it's going to help me so I think
that they care about their depending on
how private the data might be they care
about it but I just think that we need
to be more open with them and
transparent about what are the value
exchanges I think of it sometimes as
like if you could make the case that it
privacy on the internet is as important
as when you lock the door on your
bedroom like that if you make that make
it that clear to people but I can never
get I could never make it that clear
well it's hard cuz is it as important so
the locking the door to your bedroom you
have a lot of stuff that's in your
bedroom that you might not want people
to see there's some stuff though that
people are doing on the internet that
they don't care about now there might be
others that they do so for example if
everybody knew that I spend a lot of
time on websites that are talking about
celebrities that might be embarrassing
to me because I might know what the
average might like mutton anybody but my
friends to know that but if it's just
that I'm going and I'm looking at black
shoes because I might blend black shoes
for an event I might not care about that
so it just depends on what the data is
if its data that's inherently private
data about your medical condition or
your financial situation then I think
that that's different but if it's just
data about maybe their their usage of
certain internet sites maybe they don't
care so i think it's just again about
that transparency in that value exchange
what do you want to say to the new
developer out there the new person who's
creating a new app a new tech company
that is collecting a lot of data what is
the first thing they should know well
what I think is really important about
collecting data right outside of the box
is really you won't know it may be what
you want to do with that data you know a
year from now but I think it's important
to understand the value to you for you
keeping that data for the length of time
so if you really kept that data for a
year are you going to go back and be
able to mine that data and make it
valuable to you I think the answer might
be known so there should be like a
certain period of time that you're
starting to overwrite that data with
data and this is one of the things I
like developers to think about with data
may come a reward but there's all scott
risk and so you need to think about you
know three years from now if you have
data that has that you've been
collecting over that period of time and
then you get a request or subpoena or an
NSA requests you're going to have to go
and search through all of that data you
don't want that for lots of reasons for
your users as well as just for your
company so it's really just thinking
about what that data can do for you and
how when does it lose its value to you
and again one of the things i would say
is be really transparent with big data
comes big responsibility yes exactly
well thank you very much to know this is
a lot of fun for reason TV I'm home
you